well it's completely [ __ ] ridiculous
that the the laptop is just running out
of power
the fact that the laptop runs on the
power completely threw me off and it's
just completely ridiculous it should not
be happening like plug the laptop in
matches it over
[Music]
should be the winner
[Music]
how much of that second game hunts would
you attribute to the first game and what
happens
you start out with a masterpiece how
would you summarize it chess speaks for
itself
is it something special doing this
against Magnus hunts
let's see Anisha just see someone who's
going to face the Wrath I think some of
the decisions I made were just
absolutely insane like to go
King F3 to E4 I was just trusting my
instinct
[Music]
this this position quite uh like it I
did not let it get any no I've actually
blocked all social media I don't use
social media
yeah yeah the fact that I'm alive at
this moment is is a is a miracle because
after I lost his first game ridiculous I
think I was really just ready to just go
into the ocean and uh never never come
back